it's hard to imagine a celebrated actor
in a bad film well not only does it
happen but more often than you would
think some of their worst movies are
released the same year as their best
after years of being a steady character
actor Michael Keaton came back in a
massive way in 2014 headlining the best
picture-winning drama Birdman reaffirmed
that Keaton not only had leading man
chops but that he could surprise people
even decades after his star-making
performances in Mr Mom Beetlejuice and
Batman it was a revelatory turn that
breathed exciting life into Keaton's
filmography Birdman wasn't the only
motion picture he appeared in that year
2014 also saw the actor showing up in
one of the weakest titles in his
filmography the instantly forgotten
video game adaptation Need for Speed the
misguided Aaron Paul vehicle saw Keaton
playing Monarch the host of an illicit
racing competition Heaton's work in the
movie sees him largely isolated from all
the other prominent characters speaking
expository dialogue into a microphone
while it did give Keaton a chance to
deliver some amusingly over-the-top
dialogue the role was otherwise
appropriately forgettable for such a
disposable action feature this was the
total opposite of the Bold work in
Birdman that would give Keaton his
creative Renaissance at least the Dismal
quality of Need for Speed allowed
audiences to further appreciate Keaton
getting a chance at a big comeback later
that year
Devil in a Blue Dress wasn't a box
office monster when it first opened in
theaters in 1995 but in the years since
audiences have grown to love this
neo-noir anchored by Denzel Washington
it's hard not to be captivated by
Washington as detective easy Rollins
meanwhile the visual palette of the
feature is gorgeous not to mention
impressive in how it juggles classic
Noir motifs without sacrificing its own
creative impulses her name was Ruby
Hanks from Lake Charles Louisiana
and I suppose all she really wanted was
a place to fit in even with Washington's
impressive resume Devil in a Blue Dress
stands alongside the likes of Malcolm X
as the man's greatest star vehicle
however Devil in a Blue Dress wasn't the
only Denzel Washington film occupying
movie theaters in 1995. this same year
saw the debut of virtuosity an action
thriller following Washington as a
former cop tasked with taking down a
virtual criminal played by Russell Crowe
who's broken out into reality the
feature was decimated by critics and now
ranks as one of the more puzzling
Endeavors in Washington's filmography
after several years of being a notable
supporting character actor and
occasionally headlining Box Office
non-starters Oscar Isaac made the leap
to successful leading man in 2013 with
inside Lou and Davis playing the titular
cash strapped folk musician Isaac was a
revelation he delivered talented
performances before but never to this
degree with so much screen time and a
rich Cohen Brothers screenplay at his
disposal Isaac crafted a character whose
pain could simultaneously irritate and
devastate the audience have you ever
heard the expression it takes two to
tango Isaac was also one of the leads of
in secret an erotic Thriller from
director Charlie Stratton that began
playing at film festivals in 2013
whereas inside Lou and Davis became a
beloved Masterpiece in secret was hated
by critics many of the biggest
complaints were leveled at the features
erratic tone and its unappealing visual
aesthetic
though it had a one week qualifying run
in 2014 to ensure it could compete in
the 87th Academy Awards the North
American theatrical release of Still
Alice didn't begin in Earnest until
January 2015. once this film landed in
theaters audiences were quickly taken
aback by Julianne Moore's staggering
lead performance as a woman dealing with
Alzheimer's it's a brutal Arc to watch
unfold but more handles all the finer
details and quieter moments beautifully
in a career of memorable go For Broke
performances in movies like Boogie
Nights her work in Still Alice still
registers as commanding and impressive a
few weeks after Still Alice began its
big screen Journey another movie
featuring more landed in theaters this
project was Seventh Son a fantasy epic
that saw more occupying the role of the
film's villain there was no shortage of
star power in Seventh Son including Jeff
Bridges as a wise wizard but it wasn't
enough to salvage an expensive disaster
not even more Banting up as a baddie was
enough to make it a worthwhile watch
by 2009 Jeff Bridges had been scoring
high-profile roles in movies for nearly
40 years in that time he'd explored
countless genres established several
iconic characters and been nominated for
four Academy Awards a staple of big
screen storytelling Bridges was long
overdue for an Oscar that's just what
happened when he played tormented
country singer Otis bad Blake in crazy
hearts in 2009. it's a role that
exploits Bridge's own legacy to create a
character whose aching weariness seems
so real you believe Blake has been
through the fire and flames for decades
it's a fantastic performance from
Bridges and one that gave Hollywood and
general moviegoers alike a chance to
appreciate his gifts that same year
though ridges anchored the open road
with Justin Timberlake one would imagine
that combining two instantly
recognizable names like that would have
resulted in something at least
interesting but the open road became one
of Jeff Bridge's most detested features
the movie was plagued by rampant
criticisms suffering from weak riding
and a lack of interesting material for
Bridges to handle
looking to expand his image Beyond just
romantic comedies like fool's gold and
How to Lose a Guy in 10 Days Matthew
McConaughey began to tackle challenging
roles and work with intriguing otors in
2012 embracing a wide variety of
projects meant that there were going to
inevitably be some Duds and such a dud
came in the form of The Paperboy a
melodrama from director Lee Daniels
McConaughey was one of the many actors
in The ensemble cast grappling with a
thick accent and a plot that could be
borderline incomprehensible
I'm Your Arms Wide Open I'm your fans
The Paperboy has moments where it comes
to life but it's mostly Awash thanks to
lackluster style and extremely
predictable third act narrative twists
on the other hand McConaughey also
managed to headline one of his very best
movies in 2012 by taking on a supporting
role in Bernie playing an officer who
seems to be the only one suspicious of
Jack Black's titular protagonist makana
hey portrays a unique character compared
to his usual roles while simultaneously
demonstrating his death comedic chops
it's hard to believe Gary Oldman didn't
score an Oscar nomination until 2011
with the Espionage Thriller thinker
Taylor Soldier Spy regardless the
nomination was well deserved old men
really excelled at communicating so much
interior life for his character within
the intentionally restrained Ambiance of
the feature famous for his enjoyably
over-the-top displays of acting Tinker
Taylor Soldier Spy reminded us all that
Oldman could do extraordinary subdued
work as well that same year Oldman
showed up as an antagonistic figure
armed with a gigantic metal elephant in
Red Riding Hood The Talented actor is no
stranger to showing up for supporting
roles in schlocky genre fair but Red
Riding Hood is one of the most tedious
and forgettable movies in his career a
paint by numbers attempt to make a moody
Twilight knockoff with iconography
lifted from the Little Red Riding Hood
fairy tale Red Riding Hood is neither
fun nor trashy enough to be worth a
watch
while some people remember Robin
Williams for his rapid fire wit and
skillful Impressions and especially
lasting quality of his career is his
gift for warmth Williams could exude an
inviting Aura like nobody's business and
that trait was particularly apparent in
his role as Dr Sean McGuire in Goodwill
Hunting in this film Williams skillfully
played a man who could help withdrawn
college students come out of their
shells while simultaneously conveying
that his character was somebody
struggling to let go of his own past it
was a complicated role but one to which
Williams lent incredible authenticity
and vulnerability the same year Williams
was crushing it in Goodwill Hunting he
also anchored the comedy dud Father's
Day with Billy Crystal one would imagine
that pairing up Williams and Crystal
would have inevitably resulted in
something memorable or amusing but alas
Father's Day is the worst kind of Comedy
utterly forgettable even with Williams
sometimes putting too much energy into
the film's big comedic set pieces
Father's Day was a snooze while this
feature has faded away from the public
Consciousness films like Goodwill
Hunting exemplify why Robin Williams
won't be forgotten the idea of Amy Adams
playing Lois Lane sounds like a great
concept Lois is a Charming character who
has endured in pop culture for a reason
and the acting chops of Adams could lend
her new levels of depth rather than
being overwhelmed by CGI Mayhem or
reduced to a cornball love interest an
actor of her caliber had the potential
to stand out and command the screen
2013's Man of Steel introduced Adams's
lowest giving fans plenty of reasons to
look forward to more unfortunately the
2016 follow-up Batman vs Superman dawn
of Justice offers Adams nothing of
substance to do her version of Lois Lane
is saddled with a dreary detective
storyline that feels extraneous from the
central Batman Superman plotline worse
her Exposition heavy investigation
scenes never give Adams a chance to
indulge in her greatest strengths as an
artist thankfully eight months after
dawn of Justice audiences would see
atoms in a more substantive role as
Louise Banks the linguist who functions
as the protagonist of arrival Adams is
endlessly compelling in this part and
provides a distinctly human anchor to
orient a plotline involving human beings
trying to communicate with aliens I will
take that as a compliment
yeah well it is before he became Captain
America Chris Evans was playing another
Marvel Comics superhero Johnny Storm AKA
The Human Torch his second outing is the
character came with Fantastic Four Rise
of the Silver Surfer which attempted to
work more of the weird Cosmic elements
from Fantastic Four Comics into the big
screen version of Marvel's first family
unfortunately these Ambitions just
resulted in an even more underwhelming
movie than the already subpar 2005
Fantastic Four feature the
interpretations of famous comic book
characters like Galactus and Rise of the
Silver Surfer were terrible and the
films brought attempts at comedy weren't
much better that same year Evans also
headlined one of the very best Works in
his filmography Sunshine a Danny Boyle
directorial effort anchored by Killian
Murphy Evans got far meteor and
atmospherically interesting material to
work with in sunshine not only that but
the project demonstrated his gift for
working well within Ensemble casts a
trait that would suit him perfectly in
later Motion Pictures like snow piercer
Knives Out And even his final two
appearances as Captain America Rise of
the Silver Surfer proved that not even
the charm of Chris Evans could Salvage
this ill-conceived vision of a superhero
team by contrast Sunshine offered a
glimpse into the kind of talents Evans
can express when he's given the room and
some quality writing to work with
in 2003 tiptoes debuted on the American
Film Festival scene inspiring moviegoers
everywhere to ask where Matthew
McConaughey and Gary Oldman were going
in their leading man careers but Oldman
and McConaughey weren't the only ones
slumming it in this miscalculated Motion
Picture Peter Dinklage was also in the
cast of tiptoes sadly not even the
versatility and exceptional talents of
Dinklage were enough to lift this film
out of the gutter decades after its
release tiptoes remains a pop culture
punching bag and a low point for many of
the actors involved that same year
Dinklage anchored the easy going and
quietly moving Indie feature The Station
Agent a movie hailing from Spotlight
director Tom McCarthy The Station Agent
gave Dinklage ample room to play a
fascinating protagonist with an
incredibly Gruff exterior hiding
complexities that ensure you can't turn
away from him I don't really say much to
you
it's not it's not needless to say
Dinklage is remarkable in The Station
Agent establishing the kind of quality
performances audiences would see him
deliver countless times over the years
to come since The Station Agent garnered
Dinklage considerable Awards attention
it'd be easy to forget that the same
year that this film was released he was
connected to a movie as despised as
tiptos
foreign